[Musique]
joannie courchesne 30 ans termine sa
journée de travail elle est gérante de
ce dépanneur
et le boulot est fini aussi pour son
conjoint carla b 30 ans il supervise
l'équipe de maintenance dans cet édifice
ils sont à quelques kilomètres de leur
domicile à saint cyrille de wendover
j'ai nié les faits
[Musique]
une fois chez eux joignez carle sont des
éleveurs de bovins de boucherie
c'est un troupeau de vaches croisés et
pur sang qui leur donne des animaux
vendus pour la viande ou la reproduction
ce temps qu'on a acheté bleus trois
semaines en ontario dans une vente
d'euler hermes pure simple ça c'est 9 mm
un vent d'amour eux
[Musique]
comme leurs parents n'étaient pas
agriculteurs ils se sont installés en
partant de zéro
la première est amusé avec ma secte
rouen verges de l'année quand j'ai fini
mon cours en production bovine le gérer
à l'aide d'un bouton b d'un énorme des
financières pour voir la seconde
non
quand joannie est arrivé dans sa vie non
seulement il a dit oui qu'à
l'agriculture
elle a voulu des vaches r forme pure
sans ça a été déporté inquiet du tout ça
est une verge à toutes les années
pendant 15 mai à 8 heures
aujourd'hui ils ont 35 beh c'est un
petit troupeau mais la taille idéale
quand on travaille ailleurs à temps
complet on a choisi et d'avoir à peu
près 30 35 verges parce que dans le fond
ça joue bien avec notre travail
extérieur si on n'arrête plus de vaches
ça fonctionnerait pochon
mais un troupeau de taille réduite ne
génère pas assez de revenus pour que
joannie et carl puisse acquérir une
terre
il aurait besoin d'au moins 80 acres
pour leurs troupeaux à 6000 $ l'âcre
dans la région c'est une fortune c'est
pourquoi il loue les champs pour les
pâturages et achète le foin avec le
marché du boeuf qui est en fluctuation
c'est dur de dire qu'on achète une time
ton ennemi millions qui est un morceau
avec les animaux le même le banquier
vous le dit le premier
[Musique]
sa vocation l'instant on reste ici
nontron et
mes parents sont présents beaucoup
beaucoup avec nous pour nous aider
et pour les aider à augmenter leurs
revenus
ils mettent des efforts dans
l'amélioration génétique du troupeau ont
regardé catalogne on regarde ce qu'est
ce qui peut nous améliorer ton est
souvent beaucoup si les vagues
[Musique]
dans le couple chacun a ses forces et
ses responsabilités johan est plus
loquace comme beaucoup tout ce qui n'est
pas prêt à ce qu'est ce qui est devant
des mots a réussi tout le temps trouver
quelqu'un pour acheter nos ennemis
fressoz elle nous donne une grosse plus
value est pour sa part car le voit à la
nourriture et au bien-être du troupeau
[Musique]
à chacun la recette idéale en
agriculture pour karl et joignez c'est
un travail à l'extérieur et une ferme à
échelle humaine
[Musique]
chaque gère nos chaque personne en
agriculture à sa place moi je restais
sur chaque projet tchèque personnes et
est aussi importante que ça soit une
ferme de millevaches ou une ferme de 10
verges
la personne qui dit se dévoue à son
entreprise je pense que c'est ce qu'il
est pour tous un par tant de violence
il
[Musique]